mais nous débutons ce journal avec la
primaire de la droite et du centre qui a
livré son verdict de hier soir tout à
fait Haussmann après des mois de
campagne les électeurs ont tranché la
droite et le centre on dorénavant leurs
candidat officiel en vue de la
présidentielle de mai prochain à il
s'agit de François Fillon près de 3
millions de votants en France se sont
prononcés en faveur de l'ancien Premier
ministre de Nicolas Sarkozy est le
résultat provisoire fait état de
66,5% des suffrages la vérification des
chiffres est encore en cours et c'est
sensiblement le même résultat que l'on
retrouve dans les Yvelines cette fois-ci
le résultat est définitif
65,4% pour François Fillon et on notera
que la participation est en hausse de
3000 personnes ils sont
166122 à avoir fait le déplacement hier
écoutez d'ailleurs ces quelques
réactions à la sortie des bureaux de
vote pour les électeurs cette primaire
va permettre débat présidentiel de
gagner en clarté
je suis venu voter aujourd'hui à la
primaire parce que j'estime que la
France n'est plus la France
qu'aujourd'hui la France est déclinée
après cinq années catastrophique et je
pense qu'il nous faut un homme avec une
ambition grosse comme ça pour pouvoir
sortir notre pays de la bisse dans
lequel il se trouve dans le contexte
actuel entre la gauche et la droite ça
permet d'avoir une idée des futurs
présidentielles je trouve ça très très
bien parce que moi on a le choix de
c'est un premier c'est un premier vote
avant le vote des présidentielles donc
je trouve ça très très très bien puisque
au moins on peut choisir pour qui qui va
représenter telle ou telle partie et je
dirais même que moi s'il y a une
primaire bien évidemment à gauche j'irai
aussi voter je trouve ça tout à fait
logique après que ça soit un débat
d'idées
lors de lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle
concernant les réactions des
responsables politiques à présent du
côté des vainqueurs François Fillon elle
a sénatrice Sophie prima numéro 2 les
républicains dans les Yvelines soutient
de la première heure estime que le
regroupement va maintenant se faire
naturellement le score sans appel à sur
la légitimité du désormais candidat à la
présidentielle selon elle
je pensais que les écarts allaient se
resserrer au cours du deuxième tour et
en réalité je suis agréablement surprise
parce que je pense que c'est un vote
d'adhésion qui s'est qui s'est exprimé
en réalité les Français de droite et du
centre se sont retrouvés davantage dans
le positionnement François Fillon qui
est un positionnement de droite très
rapidement avant la fin de l'année on va
on va tous se réunir moi je vais avec
David Douillet lancer un comité
départemental inviter tous les gens qui
sont investis dans cette primaire
autre soutien à François Fillon Suzanne
blanc c'est la première adjointe de
Montigny le Bretonneux l'élu elle est
républicains estiment que cette victoire
n'aurait jamais pu se produire sans le
combat mener sur le terrain par les
militants il y a eu une armée de
mobiliser derrière François Fillon vous
savez on n'a pas ménagé notre peine loin
sans faux que ce soit ici à Montigny que
ce soit dans toutes les villes les
villages de France il a fait un énorme
travail lui-même sur le terrain énorme
énorme énorme il est allé même dans des
villages et c'est très important c'est
extrêmement important parce qu'il y
avait des Français que l'on entendait
plus qui on parlait et s'en est inspiré
et il s'en est bien inspiré et puis je
vous dis moi je crois que cette cette
fantastique armée qui a été autour de
lui à bosser vraiment il y a pas
d'autres mots on a fait énormément on a
on s'est énervé comme dans toutes les
campagnes on avait pas y arriver on
n'est pas assez de Chi on avait pas
assez de ça voilà mais ça ça a été ça a
été vraiment révélateur avant d'écouter
les soutiens à Alain Juppé un mot
concernant la commune de Montigny le
Bretonneux ou siège d'ailleurs Suzanne
Blunt comme une plutôt centriste alors
jupée totalise 48% c'est l'un de ces
meilleurs scores et voici la réaction du
maire Michel Laugier également président
de 50 ans en Yvelines et il a un message
à faire passer alors que débute une
toute autre campagne
un écart plus serré qu'au niveau
national sur Montigny mais bon Montigny
tu nous commune différente et Montigny a
toujours eu un comportement très
centriste dans ces choix moi ce que
j'attends du prochain Président de la
République surtout c'est que il facilite
le travail des élus donc il ne faut plus
de liberté liberté d'entreprendre
liberté de gérer au niveau local et
surtout que audio si les moyens qui vont
avec afin que les les habitants puissent
être satisfaits de la gestion de leur
ville Alain Juppé battuet pourtant les
soutiens dans le département des
Yvelines été nombreux exemples avec Carl
le livre c'est le maire de Poissy il
avait été également animé les différents
débats parisiens les différents meetings
le combat qui nous attend aujourd'hui et
pendant six mois c'est bien le défi de
remporter l'élection présidentielle j'en
veux pour preuve le déplacement sur
chacune des manches de cette primaire de
plus de 4 millions de Français c'est
légitimer le vainqueur François Fillon a
désormais tout le pouvoir entre
guillemets de pouvoir bien se préparer
avec toutes les sensibilités mais il est
légitimé par ces Français qui souhaitent
l'alternance si du côté de la droite on
sonne globalement l'heure du
rassemblement la situation est un peu
plus complexe avec les centristes de
l'UDI et surtout du MoDem François
Bayrou c'était engagé vous le savez au
côté à d'Alain Juppé depuis plus d'une
semaine il juge très sévèrement le
programme le projet de François Fillon
voici elle se compense Bruno Millien
c'est le président du MoDem dans le
département des Yvelines également
conseillers régionales Île-de-France on
va prendre le temps il faut qu'on
réfléchisse ça va pas se faire on va pas
faire ça du jour au lendemain d'abord
c'est pas c'est pas dans nos gènes dans
nos habitudes on prend toujours le temps
de la réflexion pour se décider et je
peux pas parler à la place de François
Bayrou nous on va surtout travailler
essayer de proposer une autre
alternative et on verra on verra on
verra l'accueil que nous réserve cette
nouvelle alternative qu'on va proposer
la gauche et l'extrême droite
connaissent donc que maintenant le nom
de leur adversaire et si le FN se
réjouit de cette victoire en appelant à
une confrontation de projet le PS tente
déjà de mettre en marche le
rassemblement écoutez tout d'abord
François Siméoni c'est le responsable FN
dans les Yvelines et également Sandrine
grand gambe c'est la responsable du PS
toujours dans le département
c'est vraiment le candidat ultra libéral
qui porte ce projet de casse mais je
dirais même d'injustice sociale parce
que regardez par exemple l'augmentation
de la TVA deux points qui prévoit qui
savent toucher ça va bien plus toucher
les plus humbles à côté de ça il suffit
donc véritablement nous on porte un
projet patriotes radicalement en
opposition avec ce candidat du système
quoi les élections sont encore dans
suffisamment longtemps pour qu'ils
puissent avoir des changements et c'est
pas du tout sûr moi je
n'imagine pas du tout comme certains le
fait que une personne comme Fillon soit
soit au deuxième tour dans les périodes
de tourmente il y a des règles il y a
des valeurs qui sont les nôtres qui
doivent être notre boussole et je pense
que c'est la seule manière de de trouver
le meilleur d'entre nous le meilleur
candidat pour affronter une droite qui
est de plus en plus réactionnaire sur le
plan sociétal et qui est quand même très
très libéral sur le plan économique donc
voilà on a des primaires on a des un
débat qui a un qui va s'organiser il
faut juste respecter nos règles et à mon
avis c'est la meilleure façon qu'il n'y
ait aucune contestation et que la
dynamique de rassemblement est soit la
dernière je considère que
que ça soit la Juppé ou François Fillon
ou Nicolas Sarkozy on a eu deux toute
façon un programme très à droite mais là
il est particulièrement en opposition
frontale avec tout ce que nous on porte
à gauche et aux parties socialesiste
voilà pour ces différentes réactions et
puis sachez que les différents soutiens
aux différents candidats à la primaire
de la droite et du centre de la onzième
circonscription des Yvelines ont décidé
de se rassembler le 13 décembre à
Fontenay-le-Fleury une réunion publique
un rassemblement pour l'alternance
organisé par le maire candidat aux
élections législatives maire d'Élancourt
Jean-Michel fourgousse